ماذا لو قامت روسيا والصين
بهجوم في وقت واحد
على أوكرانيا وتايوان؟
أين ستضع أمريكا نفسها
وعن أي دولة ستدافع؟
وهل تضيع أوكرانيا وتايوان
من يد أمريكا بهذه السهولة؟
وإن تحدثنا عن حلف الناتو بجانب أمريكا
فهم ملتزمون بالجانب الأوكراني وليس بتايوان.
أمريكا التي راح ضحية قصفها النووي
على هيروشيما وناغازاكي
أكثر من 410 آلاف شخص بين قتيل وجريح،
ومرت بسلام ولم يتخذ ضدها أي إجراء!!
وقتلت مليون عراقي في حربها على صدام
ولم يحاسبها أحد،
وعبثت في أفغانستان مدة عشرين عاماً
ولم يحاسبها أحد أيضاً.
على الجانب الآخر
فروسيا ليست ذلك الملاك الطاهر،
فمؤخراً راح ضحية قصفها المدنيون السوريون
والكثير من أطفال ونساء الشيشان.
فهل تستطيع أمريكا خوض حربين
في وقت واحد بل قد تكون ثلاثة حروب
بإضافة إيران إلى القائمة؟
أمريكا في موقف لا تحسد عليه،
كيف هو وضع جيوش هذه الدول مقارنة ببعضها،
فساعة الصفر باتت قاب قوسين أو أدنى.
ظل التخطيط العسكري الأمريكي
يقوم خلال العقود الماضية على فكرة أن الولايات المتحدة
تستطيع خوض حربين في وقت واحد،
وفي مكانين مختلفين في العالم.
لكن ماذا لو أن المكانين المختلفين
هما روسيا والصين؟
فضلاً عن عدو ثالث لأمريكا
وهي إيران ببرنامجها النووي؟
حصل المسؤولون الأمريكيون على إجازات تتحدث
عن خطط روسية لغزو أوكرانيا في
"أقرب وقت من العام الحالي".
فمناورات الصين العسكرية بالقرب من تايوان،
تبدو كأنها تدريب على غزو عسكري شامل.
بينما تشكو حكومات الصين وروسيا وإيران
من استهداف أمريكا لها بحملات لـ"تغيير النظام"،
وكل دولة لديها طموحها للهيمنة في منطقتها،
وكلها تبرر طموحاتها بالرابطة مع الناس
خارج حدودها الوطنية.
ويبدو أن الفرصة قد لاحت أمامهم لتأخذ روسيا أوكرانيا،
ولتستعيد الصين تايوان،
فيما ستنفرد إيران ببرنامجها النووي
دون مضايقات.
..
الرئيس الروسي "بوتين" يقول إن هناك عملية "إبادة"
يتعرض لها المتحدثون باللغة الروسية في أوكرانيا،
وواجب على روسيا  حمايتهم.
وترى إيران أن من واجبها حماية الإسلام،
وذلك بتطوير برنامجها النووي،
والصين ترى قدرتها على استيعاب تايوان
مرة أخرى، بينما تبدو أمريكا
مشتتة بعد خروجها العشوائي من أفغانستان.
فماذا عن ميزان القوى في جيوش هذه الدول؟
الصين وروسيا يصل عدد قواتهما المسلحة معاً
إلى أكثر من ٣ ملايين جندي،
منهم قرابة مليون جندي للقوات المسلحة الصينية فقط.
ومعظم القوات الصينية مجهزة للقتال في أي وقت،
وهو ما يرجح كفتهم عن أمريكا.
بينما يبلغ عدد القوات المسلحة الأمريكية
مليونين و245 ألف جندي.
أما في جانب الطاقة النووية المرعبة،
الفاجعة التي قد تنهي كوكب الأرض.
فتمتلك روسيا ٧٠٠٠ رأس نووي،
بينما تمتلك أمريكا العدد ذاته أو قد تقل قليلاً،
ليأتي الدور هنا على الصين
لترجح كفة الحلف ألأوراسي،
بـ ٥٠٠٠ رأس كما يقال.
أي إن الصين وروسيا تمتلكان
ضعف القوة النووية الأمريكية تقريباً،
وهي القوة الأضخم على هذا الكوكب.
بينما في جانب المركبات والآليات المدرعة
فيمتلك الحلف الأوراسي أكثر من 26 ألف مركبة قتالية،
مقابل  أكثر من 6 آلاف دبابة لأمريكا،
و40 ألف آلية مدرعة.
أعداد مهولة مرعبة في كلا الجانبين!!
على البر أيضاً تتفوق الصين وروسيا
بعدد القطع من مدافع وراجمات صواريخ
وغيرها من الأسلحة الثقيلة
بعدد يصل إلى الضعف غالباً،
وهو ما يؤشر بتفوق كاسح لأوراسيا
على أمريكا التي تعتبر أقوى دولة في العالم،
فعن أي مقارنة تتحدثون؟
في البحر أيضاً تصل عدد القطع البحرية لأوراسيا
أكثر من 900 قطعة بينما يصل عددها في أمريكا
قرابة الـ 500 قطعة،
لكن مع تفوق لأمريكا من حيث قوتها البحرية النوعية،
بأسلحة مدمرة تتضمن 11 حاملة طائرات،
و92 مدمرة و68 غواصة و8 كاسحات ألغام بحرية.
في الجو تمتلك أمريكا أكثر من 13 ألف طائرة
ومروحية عسكرية، في المقابل
يمتلك حلف أوراسيا 6500 طائرة
وهو ما ينذر بحرب لن تبقي ولن تذر،
وقد تعود بالتاريخ إلى العصر الحجري
وإلى السيف والرمح.
فالعالم كله مهدد بهذه الحرب العالمية الثالثة
التي ستمحو ربما العالم من الخريطة
ليأتي عالم آخر بدائي!!!
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
على وشك أن تواجه قوتين في مكانين مختلفين
لكن قواتها لوحدها لا تكفي،
أما ما يزيد الطين بلة هو احتمالية زيادة عدد الحروب
الأمريكية إلى ثلاثة حروب بإضافة إيران إلى القائمة.
أمريكا تلوح بحليف استراتيجي
خارج حلف الناتو ليغطي العجز الذي ستتركه روسيا
في حال انقطاع غازها بسبب الحرب،
فمن هو يا ترى؟
..
تمت تسمية دولة قطر حليفاً رئيسياً لأمريكا
غير عضو في الناتو، وهو ما سيمنح الحليفين
مزيداً من التعاون، ولأن أمريكا تخاف أن يبتعد الأوروبيون
عن دعمها خوفاً من قطع الغاز الروسي عنهم،
فقد وجدت في قطر معوضاً لهم،
لكي لا تتركها أوروبا وحيدة في مواجهة
الدب الروسي والتنين الصيني معاً،
فروسيا تمثل نصف واردات أوروبا
من الغاز بـ 177 مليار متر مكعب،
لكن قطر لا تستطيع الوصول لهذا الرقم
فجميع صادراتها لدول العالم تقدر
بـ 143 مليار متر مكعب،
بينما تقف أمريكا مكتفية ذاتياً من الغاز الطبيعي
فإنها ستجعل قطر تغذي أوروبا بالغاز
في حال نشبت الحرب لضمان تحالف أوروبا
والناتو معها في حربها،
لكن قطر ستكون أمام خطر مواجهة محتملة لروسيا
أو الصين وهو ما ينذر بكارثة قد تمحو قطر
من الخارطة في زمن قصير جداً.
أمريكا بحلف أوروبي غير مضمون وروسيا والصين
وإيران قد يتوحدون دون الحاجة لاتفاقات،
يكفي أن يقوموا بالحرب في وقت واحد.
فكيف سيكون مصير العالم بعدها؟